welcome to this video playing zhu zhu
zhu's where from okay Zuzu EFM I don't
know is from from the Netherlands and he
says I Netherlands Fleck and we've got
the Slav maybe Quinn b3m I like this
type of move this types of moves Quincy
to and queen bee three it's um not
exactly a refutation of the sloth but
you cannot get anything substantial
anyway against this opening this is
quite interesting i actually prefer
Bishop g4 which is my recommendation in
this video serious i did in german for
far as you see but it's um this is of
course i'm a playable on line four for
black ok he's got 94 really quickly hmm
why not turn yeah okay thought this
should be quite ok now ok maybe maybe
this is a tad slow what I'm doing
mmm yeah it I'm not sure if it is really
in my interest to to exchange so many
nights okay but and now it's taking with
the bishop I interestingly enough yeah
maybe in night night takes was a bit
technical am unreliable okay f3 is the
idea is to play a quick be4 control the
center and we would deform yeah this is
plate to to have something against c5
with them with the form on the horizon
his bishop on g6 is a slightly
problematic piece ok does he want to
play maybe you could win a 6m maybe ok
so that was it was clear and after a
bishop deform he's one he wants to play
I don't mind that I like to play this
end game that's a no problem at all
should I take it and play Queen f2 or
should I play three Neff to hear let him
exchange on deform ok there is Queen B 2
wheel Queen f2 bishop d 4 24 queen bee
too but this looks sick I all get be
seven so he cannot do that really you
will take on deform
besides maybe they're even Queen traps
somewhere yeah hmm that's interesting
cool they cannot t again because of the
the pin
I can with night if form provoke the
capture I can let's do that i'd like to
false metal cm jack no it's actually
he's got a slight technical problem now
what is he doing with the bill tonight
if he goes Knight e5 there is f4 f4 and
possibly f5 making it very tough for the
bishop here on g6 if he goes rook da
this rookie one and he lose the piece
due to the pin and where is it going
actually if it wants to move it can go
to f6 but this is strategically very
undesirable I mean besides possible
technical problems but now or this
movement which has obvious drawbacks
let's consider right night will go to a
6 probably 22 to get back into the game
I wonder maybe I should go Bishop f12 to
have this Knight b6 idea
like night a six-night be 60 k 12 Bishop
f7 maybe but i'll do that now this is a
good post for this night and now root T
one route 28
group d 8 or look look the seven look d
7 this may be night see five rookies
sama is still very good forward yeah
I'll do that the threatens bishop a six
winning our winning an important pawn he
right here the question is to check
first to check first and then we'll be
seven yeah why not check why not
actually he cannot enter post because we
have seven wins instantly and now look
is soon yeah this is this looks a very
tricky now let's see and of course I'd
love to go on the 7th is 97 normals the
1970s got rocked e8 rook the end time
morning not sure what to do
maybe I can can prove prepare prepare
that 9797 now I can I can take it but it
was it was the loss anyway I believe
only his only hope was my 30-something
seconds black resigns it was just just
to better position roti I said I didn't
have enough time to find a clear win but
there is there is more than one I
believe look at this what what is the
comp sign k3 edited this it keeps maybe
my way was okay i mean clicking f2 is
just a waiting move and now it wants to
go look to d6 but this does not spoil
anything right you know it is even what
I played as a win ok this is blundering
the rook here but he's got no move he
simply got no more in g7 s is not
defensible just just something like that
is going to happen yeah it I don't know
it got bad really quickly maybe maybe 97
was a bit a bit too clever in a way here
it's it's it's technically already very
tricky chap you look at this various the
night going i mean i piayed is obviously
not ideal but where do you go where do
you go I mean 95 I'm pushing f4 and
something like that this Bishop is
almost trapped I mean this is probably
not yet working don't see a trap now I
can I can play this of course but now
he's got this this types of this
types of moose but I can I can prepare
that maybe something like that Tim this
is just just a fantastic position for
white it's probably am probably winning
already I don't go if he goes here well
the night is just those two pieces only
looking at protected squares and I have
I have the default I have night coming
here and the queenside is slightly
weakened here why does an excellent
shape just to show the computer is on
plus two and with equal material so it's
actually very likely that I win some
material on the queenside nameplate this
and now okay there there are many ways
to go but this looks like it should keep
should keep enough yeah maybe here
Bishop f7 is a bit tougher now no it's I
think it's gone now yeah the compass on
plus three so not defensible probably oh
look the eight rook da this even is even
more forcefully of course i was i only
had this idea to double on the seventh
but this is this is oops quite quite
nice and resins i guess a 497 this is
quite quite okay quite okay yeah it was
several surprising how quickly this town
went downhill may be here you should
should just immediately take or maybe
i'll go back to c7 I don't know it looks
a bit better for white because of those
pieces not being optimally placed but
it's still very very solid this position
okay thanks for watching